but the benefit of those you don't know
who didn't know the strike was settled
and just came home from the movies
welcome to an evening of fun and games
were George and Martha and Oscar to make
a special presentation I am pleased to
introduce a former Texan who went to
Washington as a presidential assistant
and was later elected president of the
Motion Picture Association of America
mr. Jack Valenti
thank you Bob
long before my active participation in
the affairs of the motion picture
industry I was aware of the presence
among you of an unusual and gifted man
whose keen and practical mind has for 30
years in a force and the affairs of this
Academy throughout his career he never
treated serious business as trifles nor
made trifles his serious business
always and in everything he never lost
his humor for his dedication as he
advanced the cause of his industry and
the highest standards of excellence he
both encouraged and enlarged I must
confess to you I sleep a little better
at night because I am able now to
proclaim his services to picture makers
and picture goers aligned to this
distinguished gentleman from Georgia a
former winner of the Jean Hersholt
Humanitarian Award an authentic
statesman the motion picture industry
and community the Academy's board
gratefully presents a special award to
mr. why Frank Freeman
thank you jack it has been a great
privilege which I've enjoyed to be a
member of the motion picture industry it
has also been a great privilege to have
saved for many years on the board of the
Academy and to have been associated with
a group of men dedicated to the
betterment and advancement of this
industry there was never anything
selfish in their motives I want to
express to them my heartfelt
appreciation for this award and to you
jack
I want to say that we are fortunate that
you've joined us as president the motion
picture producers Association and I feel
highly honored that you were the one
selected to give me this award